nous n'avions jamais vu si loin dans
l'univers les images et les spectres
captée par le télescope spatial james
webb offre une nouvelle perspective à
l'humanité
chaque image offerte par web est une
découverte scientifique en soit la nasa
en dévoile aujourd'hui 5 l'image de
fascinantes nébuleuse de gigantesques
nuages de gaz et de poussière l'analyse
de l'exoplanète wasps 96 des composés
essentiellement de gaz où l'on a trouvé
la présence d'eau
et puis le groupement compact de
galaxies une façon de montrer au monde
entier un aperçu des prouesses dont est
capable jane's web le plus puissant
télescope jamais conçu et moi-même qui
scientifiques qui devraient être habitué
à ce genre de performance dont moi même
je suis surpris de voir la qualité de
ces images là et ça fait six mois que ça
dure et enfin on peut départager avec le
public aux quatre coins du monde des
astronomes attendait ce moment à
longueuil à l' agence spatiale
canadienne où des dizaines d'employés
s'étaient rassemblés la fébrilité était
palpable
c'est quelque chose qu'on attendait
depuis très très longtemps car ces
images pourront changer notre
compréhension de l'univers
ce que web va nous permettre de faire
c'est de regarder l'univers avec une
profondeur beaucoup plus grande qu'avant
une précision beaucoup plus grande
qu'avant et d'aller chercher des
informations qu'on n'avait pas encore il
faut rappeler que le canada a joué son
rôle dans la mise en oeuvre de la
mission il fournit deux instruments
essentiels le guide heures de précision
et le nourrissent le spectrographe
imageur du télescope tous les canadiens
doivent ressentir une fierté j'espère
aujourd'hui est la mission de jane's web
commence à peine c'est vraiment nouveau
chapitre dans l'histoire de l'astronomie
posté à 1,5 million de km de la terre le
télescope devrait fonctionner pour les
20 prochaines années et répondre en
partie aux questions des humains ici qui
me permettra au canada montréal